هدى احمد سيده ثلاثينيه اجبرتها ظروف
الحياه وتعني في زوجها الى طلب الطلاق رغم
صعوبه العيش ومواجهه المجتمع كما تقول
اسباب الطلاق بالنسبه الي كانت كلش هوايه
معاناه استمرت خمس سنوات عندي اثنين اطفال
الاسباب اللي دفعتني اطلق ان هو ما كان
يصرف على البيت انسان قاعد يشتغل يوم
وقاعد عشره ايام
كان يضربني وياذيني اي حقوق كان ما مسويها
الي كحقوق زوجيه هدى ليست الاولى او حتى
الاخيره فحالات الطلاق تتزايد وبمعدل تسع
حالات في الساعه الواحده ارقام صادمه
وربما مخيفه لكنها تعكس واقعا مسكوت عنه
في المجتمع العراقي بالنسبه للحق حصلت مني
اي حقوق لا ماديه ولا معنويه
يحاربني حاليا كل ما اطلب النفقه بالقانون
وبالشرع احد من عائلتي يروح لبيتهم يطلب
نفقه يحاربني ويبتزني بالاطفال بعد الطلاق
لحد الان يعني تطلقت واشتغل بالخياطه وما
حصلت منه اي حقوق
اكثر من ربع حالات الزواج في العراق تنتهي
بالطلاق بحسب احصائيات شبهه رسميه تعددت
الاسباب والطلاق واحد العنف الاسري وزواج
القاصرات وعدم الاستقرار المادي اسباب
كافيه لانهاء الحياه الزوجيه هنا البصره
وبغداد كبريات مدن العراق تاتي على راس
قائمه حالات الطلاق الاعلى في البلاد
العنف الاسري اللي اخذ اشكال وحشيه في
المجتمع العراقي سببها ايضا وهذا يعني
ارتفع بدرجه كبيره
زواج القصر
كبير بالعمر ياخذ له طفله كبيره بالعمر
تاخذ لها شاب اصغر من عندها فما يتفاهمون
والاكبر والاسوا اذا كانوا اثنينهم اطفال
اذا لا يحتاج لهم تربيه انا اقولهم تعالوا
كونوا اسره وربوا لا حلولا ناجعه الى الان
تسهم بايقاف مؤشر حالات الطلاق المرتفع
والذي ينذر بتفكك اسري تتبعه اثار
اجتماعيه واقتصاديه مدمره على المجتمع لكن
منا جعفر الناشطه في حقوق المراه ترى ان
ايقاف العنف الاسري ربما يكون سببا في
تقليل تلك الحالات الحلول بصراحه هي لازم
تكون حلوه التشريعيه اول شيء
بتشريع قوانين تحد من العنف الاسري لان
السبب الاول
للطلاق وزياد حالاته بالوقت بالفتره
الاخيره هو وجود العنف داخل الاسره بشكل
كلش كبير ماكو معالجات قانونيه لهذا الع
الاسري يتم التعامل ويا الموضوع من يعني
من قبل جهات حكوميه ومن قبل منظمات مجتمع
مدني لكن نفتقر الى وجود قانون يعالج هذا
العنف الاسري لا تواجهوا معظم المطلقات
الاثار النفسيه للطلاق فقط بل تتعداها الى
عوز مادي
واستغلال المجتمعي لحاله باتت تشكل تحديا
حقيقيا
للاجيال المقبله سامر الكبيسي العربيه
بغداد لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات